Korea's most recession proof industry is prostitution.
It makes up 4 percent of GDP and as an industry has an estimated value of  22 billion dollars a year.
Currently, over 500,000 women work directly as prostitutes.
Prostitution is everywhere but everyone ignores it as if it doesn't exist.
Despite being outlawed in 1948,...
...it sometimes seems as law enforcement just turns a blind eye to it.
To satisfy the public's growing outrage to clean it up,...
...especially with regard to underage prostitution,...
...a major "crackdown" began in 2004 with a new anti - prostitution law.
One of the effects of the crackdown was to drive prostitution even more underground.
Just a few years later, it's almost business as usual.
The names have changed and locations, too.
Amazingly, places to buy sex often have the biggest neon sign on the entire building,...
...but even without a sign there are myriad ways of recognizing what is being sold.
Even when prostitutes or pimps are arrested,...
...the justice system may not see that a crime has been committed.
One judge has decided that massage parlors where sex can be bought,...
...though technically violating laws against prostitution,...
...were also performing an "indispensable service" to the community.
As a result charges against the accused were dropped.
Maybe the problem lies here.
As long as these types of attitudes towards...
...prostitution and sex trafficking are held by even the highest members of the legal profession,...
...there is no real hope of eradicating it.